would you go to the middle i would also
i would definitely definitely as well
you know and
just keep that king oh okay now
there's just no chance yeah white is a
porn up after all of that but that white
pawn will easily be blockaded by the
black king and this is again this is
rook end game basics
uh it's the fundamentals of rock and
games if the black king now blocks this
white pawn there's no way through it's
just a dead draw ironing's winning
chances are gone so are raj above but a
draw will be
very very nice result for the azeri
player
okay we'll just see the position repeat
itself very very shortly
nothing to play for here
they're just going through the motions
and then aronian will admit defeat and
there we go it is a draw and bob takes
it oh look at that his reaction is that
emotions is he just very tired we do
remember tears from when he won the air
things masters in the finals against
levon aronian right well it must have
been very stressful for rajabov to play
this fourth game